a convoy of tractors heading to Paris to
join a blockade of eight major roads
into the French Capital at long V 50 km
south of the city motorists had to be
diverted French Farmers have been
protesting for nearly 2 weeks they say
that riseing costs and new EU
environmental rules make their work
impossible the government has to
understand that we can't take it anymore
Farmers can't take it anymore we're at
the end of our tether we've run out of
cash we've got no money to start up
again we've got too many environmental
regulations at some point enough is
enough I don't see why other European
countries have different regulations to
us Farmers hope that the blockades near
Paris will increase pressure on the
French government to meet their demands
they say new measures announced last
week by the French prime minister fail
to address their concerns including low
pay and what they call unfair foreign
[Applause]
competition
the coming week is a week of all dangers
because either the government won't hear
us or because there'll be so much anger
that everyone will have to take
responsibility responding to the crisis
France's interior Minister deployed
15,000 police officers to secure paris's
airports and Europe's largest wholesale
Food Market South of the city calling on
officers to show
moderation we do not seek escalation we
want everyone to be respected for
offices and property to be respected we
won't allow government buildings or tax
collection buildings or grocery stores
to be damaged or trucks transporting
foreign produce to be stopped obviously
that is
unacceptable the protests come at a
sensitive time for French president
Emmanuel macron campaigning is underway
for June's European parliamentary
elections Marine leen's far-right party
is courting farmers and leading in
opinion polls the government is expected
to announce more measures soon to try
and a situation that looks increasingly
volatile Natasha Butler Al jazer
Paris make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz